part is ready to proceed
ready you're on all right from the state
Mr orders thank you your honor uh we're
obviously here in the sentencing for the
State versus Richard Alexander Murdoch
uh your honor I have prepared the
sentencing sheets signed up if I can
hand those up to the clerk
your honor uh very quickly uh the
defendant has no prior record
and the state has no uh
Victim Impact people who want to speak
at this time but I will address the
court briefly
and I don't need your honor to
repeat the evidence that your honor is
just heard for the past six weeks but it
is overwhelming
and it shows this man to be a cunning
manipulator
a man who placed himself above all
others including his family a man who
violated the trust of so many including
his friends his family
his Partners his profession
but most of all Maggie and Paul
this is a very complicated situation and
I I want to offer my condolences
to the family that has suffered here we
have tried very hard to be respectful
and sensitive regardless of what
position any person took
because this family has suffered and
they've had to suffer in the public eye
and I want to offer my condolences to
this family
I want to offer it for Maggie and Paul
and Mr Randolph too who I had the
pleasure of working with on one occasion
but the reality remains is that despite
all this attention this case is about
Maggie Murdock and Paul Murdock and I'm
so thankful that the jurors gave them a
voice
you've heard about Paul obviously there
was a vote case but you also heard him
described as a fun-loving Young Man a
person who loved life a person who would
do anything for his friends for anyone
and he's cut down as he was just
starting to live his life
you heard about Maggie you heard how
sweet she was you heard that she was a
girls girl who adapted to the
Outdoorsman life of her sons
how much she loved
her sister
and her brother-in-law
and their children
and she was cut down in the prime of her
life
both of them like everyone else was
unaware of who he really was no one who
thought they knew this man
no one who thought they were close to
this man knew who he really was in your
honor that's chilly
and I've looked in his eyes
and he liked to stare me down as he
would walk by me during this trial
and I could see
the real Alex Murdoch when he looked at
me
the depravity the callousness the
selfishness of these crimes are stunning
the lack of remorse and the effortless
way in which he lies including here
sitting right over there in this witness
stand
your honor a man like that
a man like this man should never be
allowed
to be among free law-abying citizens
again
and I would submit to you that the only
just sentence here to give Justice for
Maggie and Paul
is the maximum
and that would be two consecutive life
sentences thank you John
you indicate that no one
no victim would like to speak at this
time
with any victim like to speak at any
time during these proceedings one of the
things we did we did early on obviously
as I just said it's a very complicated
situation but we made the decision early
on we've had our victim advocate here
who's been doing a wonderful job
regardless of the viewpoints of any
individual family member to provide
Aid and service to them and we made that
decision I'm informed by our victim
Advocate that none of them wish to speak
the defense can certainly address that
but that's what I'm informed by
certainly we're offered the opportunity
as is required and I want to commend
our victim Advocate on the excellent job
she did in handling this complex
situation that we wanted to be sensitive
to because again I am not none of us are
not mindful of the fact of the suffering
of this family
I noticed slate Chief Mark Keel is here
would you like to address the court in
any matters chief
very proud of our agent's work we've
done a proud partnership with what we've
had with Attorney General's office as we
've had for many years and again we're
here exceeding Justice to serve and we
believe that
thank you
for the defense
your honor um
Mr Griffin I would have no comment the
defendant would like to address the
court though
good morning
I'm innocent
I would never hurt my wife Maggie and I
would never hurt my son Paul Paul
thank you Ryan thank you
anything further
I don't think further comment is
necessary thank you Smirnoff you'll come
the court for sentencing
this has been
perhaps one of the most troubling cases
not just for
me as a judge
for the state for the defense team
but for all of the citizens and this
Community our citizens in this state and
as we've seen
based on the media coverage there
throughout the nation
you have a
wife who's been killed murdered
son Savage Savages savagely murdered
a lawyer
a person from the respected family who
has
control Justice in this community for
over
a century
the person who's
grandfather's portrait
hang at the back of the
Courthouse
that I had to
have ordered removed
in order to ensure that a fair trial was
had by both the state and the defense
and I sat
through the trial not only have it set
through the trial but also
as the
presiding judge of the state grand jury
set through and participated
in the issuance of
search warrants of various sorts
Bond hearings and
have had to consider many things
and we have this case
and I'm also assigned to preside over
99 others
at least 99 other cases
their testimony has come up regarding
many of those other cases
I will not make any comment with regard
to any other pending matter as I have
been assigned those cases as well
it's also particularly troubling uh Mr
Murdock because
uh
as a member of the legal community in a
well-known member of the legal community
you've practiced law before me
and we've seen each other at various
occasions throughout the years
and it was especially heartbreaking for
me to
see you
've gone go in the media from being a a
grieving father
who lost the wife and a son to being
the person
indicted
and convicted of killing them
and you've engaged in such duplicitous
conduct
here in the courtroom
here on the witness stand
and as established by the testimony
throughout
the time leading from the time of the
indictment and prior to the indictment
throughout the trial to This Moment In
Time
certainly
you have no obligation to say anything
other than saying not guilty
and obviously as appeals are
probably expected or absolutely expected
I would not
expect
a confession of any kind
in fact as I've presided over
murder cases over the past 22 years I
have yet to find a
defendant who could go there
who could go back to that moment in time
when they decided to pull the trigger
or to otherwise murder someone I have
not been able to get anyone any
defendant
even those who have confessed to being
guilty
to go back and explain to me
what happened at that moment in time
when they
opted
to pull the trigger
when they opted to commit the most
Hyannis crimes
known to man
in this case
qualifies under our death penalty
statute
based on statute the statutory
aggravating circumstances of
two or more people being murdered
by the defendant by one act or pursuant
to one scheme or course of conduct
I don't question at all the
decision of the state not to pursue
a death penalty
but as I sit here in this courtroom and
look around the
many uh
portraits of
judges and other court officials
and reflect on the fact that over the
past
Century your family
including you
have been Prosecuting people here in
this courtroom
and many have received
the death penalty
probably for lesser conduct
remind me of the expression you uh
gave him a witness stand was it
Tangled
web
oh what Tango web we weave what did you
mean by that
meant when I lied I continued to lie
and the question is when will it end
when will it end
and it it's ended already for the jury
because they've
concluded that you continue to lie and
lie
throughout your testimony
and
perhaps with all the throng of people
here they
for the most part all believe or 80 90
percent 99 believe that you continue to
lie now when you your statement of
denial
to the court
perhaps you believe that it does not
matter
that there's nothing
that can mitigate
a sentence given the crime
crimes that were committed
you know a notice of Alibi was filed in
this case
by Council in November and we conducted
a hearing pre-trial hearing
in which
you claimed to have been
someplace else at the time the crime was
committed
then after all of the witnesses placed
you at the scene of the crime
at the last minute
or last minutes or days you
you
switch courses and admit it to being
there
and then that necessitated more lies and
continued to lie
and um
and I said where will it end it's
already ended for many who have heard
you and
concluded that it'll never end
but within your own soul you have to
deal with that
and I know you have to
see Paul and Maggie during the night
times when you're attempting to go to
sleep
I'm sure they come and visit you
sure
and every night
and they will continue to do so
and
and reflect on the last time they looked
you in the eyes
as you look the jury in eyes
um
I don't know
person who's always been such a
gregarious friendly person
cause of life to be Tangled in such a
weave web
such a situation that you yours have
spun into
and it's so unfortunate
because you had such a lovely family
of such friendly people and including
you
and to go from that to this
you know you're licensed to practice law
has been stripped
away from you
turn from lawyer to witness
and now
have an opportunity to make your final
appeal
as a as an ex-lawyer
and it's almost uh it was really
surprising
that you're waving this right at this
time
and if you opt to do so
it's on you I you're not compelled to
say anything
but you have the opportunity to do so
I'll tell you again
I respect this court
but I'm innocent I would never
under any circumstances hurt my wife
Maggie and I would never under any
circumstances hurt my son Paul Paul
well it might not have been you
it might have been uh
the monster you become when you
take 15 20 30 40 50 60 opioid pills
maybe you become another person
I've seen that before
the person standing before me was not
the person who committed the crime
though it's the same individual
we'll leave that at that
before announcing sentence on these
cases
with regard to all of the other pending
are any of them here in collagen or I'm
sure some of them are
half of them or
I don't have any foreignale
um there may be others that I'm not
thinking of right now
we might have worn out our welcome here
in Colleton
they have been and I'll take this
opportunity to thank Sheriff Hill and
all of the Court officials and and
really everyone I've met and and dealt
with while here in Colleton County just
been great
but without any delay we're going to
schedule some of the other matters
I know Mr harputin's
scheduling is complicated and you've
sacrificed quite a bit to be able to be
here defending
Mr murdaugh as well as the Attorney
General's office with all the other many
many things and obligations you have
and to be able to have the Attorney
General here
Alan Wilson for the period of time that
he's
devoted to being here along with
everyone else it's it's been
quite a sacrifice
but there are other victims
whose cases deserve to be heard
and this case has jumped some of those
other cases
perhaps jumped it because of the
in this case resulting in in assault on
the Integrity of the judicial system in
our state
law enforcement in our state
even during this trial the law
enforcement had been maligned
for the past five or six weeks
by
one who had access to
to the wheels of Justice
to be able to deflect
the investigation
and as a evidence pointed out in this
case the looming storm that Mr Waters
talked about
I can just imagine on that day June 7.
when a lawyer is confronted and
confesses to having stolen over a half a
million dollars
from a client
and it has a tiger like Mark Tinsley on
his tail
pursuing
discovery
in the case involving the death of
Mallory Beach
and having a father
for the most part on his death bed
I can imagine
I really can't imagine
but I know it had to have been quite a
bit
going through your mind on that day
but amazingly to have you come and
testify
that it was just another ordinary day
that my wife and son and I were out just
enjoying life
not credible not believable
you can convince yourself about it but
obviously you are have the inability
to convince anyone else about that
so
if you made any such arguments as a
lawyer you would lose every case of that
like that cases you will never have an
opportunity to argue anymore
except perhaps your own as you
sit in the Department of Corrections
anything further
Mr Meadow I sent into
the State Department of Corrections
on each of the murder indictments
in the murder of your wife Maggie
murdaugh
a sentence you for a term of the rest of
your natural life
for the murder of Paul
Merida
whom you probably love so much
a sentence you to prison
for murdering him
for the rest of your natural life
those sentences will run consecutive
under the statute involving possession
of the weapon during a violent crime
there is no sentence
where life a life sentence is imposed on
other indictments
that is the sentence of the court and
you are remanded to the State Department
of Corrections
Lord
and officers May
carry forth
on the opposition
yes sir
foreign
before we adjourn um
an order was issued
concerning maintaining the
jurors identity being anonymous
and that order was issued and for the
most part it's been complied with
except for the jury leaving the
courtroom yesterday
or not the jury but the defendant
leaving the courtroom while the jury is
still seated
um
protecting the identity of the jurors is
certainly extremely important during the
course of the trial to ensure that no
one makes contact with the jury or
attempts to influence the jury
jurors have a right to continue that
privacy beyond their jury service
but they're not obligated to do so
and
um
it would not surprise me if those if
jurors choose to come forward and to
speak and
they're encouraged to do so if that is
their desire I have no problem
whatsoever with the Jew or some
unmasking themselves
and speaking freely with the media
because they have undergone a
life-changing experience and as it
relates to many of them
but and some of them are here now and I
want them to know that should anyone
attempt to harass them
or annoy them
please let me know and I will address
the issue
secondly
um
there's a complaint now regarding the
posting of
autopsy photographs photos
they came from within the courtroom is
based on the direction of the of the
photographs that did not come from the
audience came
somehow from within the well of the
Court
the the parties have requested an
investigation of that
um
I have my hands full doing my job and I
don't attempt to conduct any
investigations Beyond the conducting of
a trial
but to the extent that law enforcement
uh
decides to review that that's the
responsibility of law enforcement
yes
and
of course one of the reasons we've
sought to
seal
graphic photos
because the parties have a right to
privacy and a right to
those matters not being publicly
disclosed
if anyone has heard about the recent
settlement that Kobe Bryant's
another Sports analogy Kobe Bryant's
wife just made with the with Los Angeles
County and others out there over
certain disclosures of information
involving the deaf
uh of Kobe Bryant
liability can be substantial and and
it's a risk for the most part
not that's not worth taking
so we'll let everyone judge themselves
accordingly within that with that regard
aside from all that our business is done
here in Colleton County
and I get to use my gavel
one a few times during this trial and
order that Court be adjourned sunny day